now Monday marks the 10th anniversary of
the collapse of a factory in Bangladesh
that killed over a thousand people the
eight-story Rana Plaza on the outskirts
of the capital of Dhaka suffered a
sudden structural failure more than 3
000 people inside the building at the
time the government made some reforms to
protect workers in the aftermath but
activists say it hasn't been enough
let's go to San Vic chowdery who joins
us now from the site of the accident in
Savannah which is just outside Dhaka so
Town very how safe is it for the Garment
workers in Bangladesh today
well before I get to that let me show
you this is where the multi-story
building Rana Plaza was and there was at
least five different uh garments Factory
in the shopping center there's nothing
there except some green weeds and plants
and you have a memorial here the only
one for the victims it's a cement
structure of a two hands with a sickle
and a hammer made by the Bangladesh
Workers Party now going back to your
question uh much has improved in
Bangladesh it does have to be saved
within last 10 years that's much to do
with International Accord and Alliance
the international labor organization in
coordination with Bangladesh government
and Bangladesh garments manufacturers
the association they have an independent
body called garments sustainability
Council which now looks after all this
matter you can hardly get any
International order if you don't comply
with the compliances which would be fire
safety Escape Route and many other
safety conditions that are imposed on
the garments Factory and they'll
regularly inspected by the authorities
many have been fined many have been
actually shut down since then now going
back to there was a rally here last
night vigil there was protest and Valley
here just about few hours ago there were
many victims victims family members
labor union workers they said not much
has been done actually in terms of
compensation for the victims at least 46
percent of the uh people who are
employed they didn't get their jobs back
and this according to action Aid many of
them are traumatized mentally ill some
are physically challenged they cannot
work some of those people got barely one
thousand dollar as the compensation was
very Mega considering the fund that was
set up had a huge amount of money and
they still complained that them getting
their adequate compensation as well as
the minimum wage the union leader said
the minimum wage is grossly inadequate
it's 95 dollar month they cannot live in
this High inflation time post-pandemic
era because cost of living is
tremendously gone up and they're
demanding for at least 200 a month much
needs to be done as far as
Rehabilitation of those workers who got
injured and out of job so there is a lot
of Demand by the government workers the
victims their families as well as the
unions and you're referring to the
Bangladesh Accord which a lot of
international uh retailers manufacturers
signed up to which you say has made a
difference on the ground but there's
still a large number of Garmin producers
I understand who haven't signed it
signed up to it uh like Walmart and
Amazon for example
what impact has that had
that's very true and many of the
garments factory work on subcontract and
they don't have to meet a lot of this
compliance and as you said a lot of the
particularly the American governments
they didn't sign up to that but they
rely on what the government
sustainability Council and the
government's manufacturer assertions
provide as a safety concern along with
what their code and Alliance did it did
improve the situation but much need to
be done it also has to be said that the
garments manufacturer said that we are
willing to raise the wages and improve
the working condition far better as long
as the buyers are willing to pay more
their squeeze sometimes even to a
break-even course with because they are
at the mercy of This Global buyers
including big like names like h m primex
Gap and Zera but they're not willing to
do that and the Garment manufacturers
are pretty much monopolized by the
international Global buyers and they
have to give what the best they can
under the circumstance okay thank you so
much for that is speaking to us there at
the site of that huge accident in Savar
just outside Dhaka